i have said a few times now
joe biden must get another major piece
of legislation done
this calendar year 2021 or it's going to
be a really tough uphill battle
in the midterms the midterms are not a
foregone conclusion traditionally
almost always when a party takes a white
house in an election year two years
later in the first midterm
they don't do well in the midterms
that's typically the way it goes
in most cases i don't believe that it is
necessarily going to go that way in 2022
but it could
and joe biden needs a major legislative
accomplishment
fortunately for america there has been
major progress on the infrastructure
bill that democrats have been trying to
figure out how on earth can we move
forward
on this with republicans this is great
news for the country
it's good news for democrats but it's
apparently disastrous news for the
former president donald trump
who has blown a gasket over this
attacking republicans now mind you
so far all that's happened is that late
last week republicans in the senate
went along with starting to debate the
infrastructure bill
they've not even voted on the package
yet okay they're just starting the
process right now
that alone has donald trump absolutely
losing it
trump putting out a statement quote
under the weak
leadership of mitch mcconnell senate
republicans continue to lose
he lost arizona he lost georgia weird i
don't remember mitch mcconnell being on
the ballot there
he ignored election fraud and he doesn't
fight
now he's giving democrats everything
they want and getting nothing in return
no deal is better than a bad deal
fight for america not for special
interests and radical democrats
rhinos are ruining america right
alongside communist democrats i don't
know if there's
anything that's accurate in that it has
real old man yelling at a cloud energy
to it if you notice but think through
the things he's saying there
first of all how is it that mitch
mcconnell lost arizona and georgia it
was
trump who lost arizona and georgia he
was the candidate
mitch mcconnell was on the ballot in
kentucky only
where he won now maybe trump is
referring to
mitch mcconnell's poor leadership led to
republican senators
losing in arizona and in georgia i
believe trump is more responsible than
mitch mcconnell for those losses as well
makes absolutely no sense
and by the way when donald trump spent
several years
insulting the late senator john mccain
who was very popular in arizona did that
help her hurt trump
in arizona but it was somehow mitch
mcconnell's fault trump barely won in
2016
eeked it out just barely winning in a
few states
lost the popular vote insulted key
people in key states
failed on kovid alienated nearly half
the country
and he thinks it couldn't be his fault
that he and his republican colleagues
lost
in arizona and georgia and if they did
it's someone else's fault for sure like
it's really really
a complete inability to take
responsibility for anything
now there's a ton of words in trump's
statement about this but it can be
translated in this way
i'm really mad that republicans are
going to go along
and give joe biden an accomplishment
because it makes me look bad because i
couldn't get infrastructure done
that's the translation of what trump is
saying and it's not even just that
trump has been pushing republicans to
reject the deal
and not work with democrats and
republicans at least for now are
signaling
we'll do it or we might do it it depends
on how the debate actually goes over the
bill
and for all the slamming liz cheney
and others as being rhinos republicans
in name only
those republicans seem much more on the
same page with each other than with
trump on almost every issue it's wild
how trump as the outlier gets to call
the others republicans in name only so
the real story here is
trump fails to see his own involvement
in the total loss of power
that republicans have experienced the
buck never seems to stop with trump when
it's not convenient
under trump republicans lost the house
in 2018 they lost the senate in 2020
they lost the white house in 2020. but
mitch mcconnell is responsible for the
states trump lost
and trump actually won anyway now back
to infrastructure
i really hope that a bill gets done
trump is furious because the senate
reaching an infrastructure deal under
biden rather than under trump
which is something he promised to do
makes him look bad and that's true it
makes him look bad
and that's all that this is donald
trump's preference
how is this patriotic trump's preference
is for american infrastructure to
crumble for four more years
if it means he can get reelected and
then sign an infrastructure bill
in 2025 he would rather infrastructure
crumble for four years
than for joe biden to get a bill done
that's not patriotic that's just about
donald trump
and it's a reminder that he knows deep
down he's not a winner
he wanted a big bipartisan agreement
biden's the one who's
maybe going to get it done instead trump
was feckless during his presidency
and he's now furious bottom line the
country needs the infrastructure deal
it would be good for the country in and
of itself as
improvements to infrastructure it would
be good economically
and it would be good if you want to make
a political analysis joe biden needs
another major accomplishment in 21.
let's see how the debate goes let's see
whether the bill
gets done and how quickly it happens
my sense is particularly with the
congressional break coming up
we're probably looking at september
october but the fact that they're
starting to debate is a very good thing
make sure you're following us on
facebook at facebook.com
david pakman show we'll have more on
this story there
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries from the world's best
filmmakers
so yes there are some documentaries on
netflix hulu amazon but
none of those streaming services give
you anything close to the selection
of what you get on curiosity stream they
have
all the newest and most critically
acclaimed documentary titles
i'm always finding amazing stuff that i
can't find
anywhere else i just actually watched
engineering the future and just super
interesting about
we really may be on the precipice here
of a total paradigm shift in terms of
what human engineering can do and
they're always adding new stuff
on curiosity stream they have
documentaries on every topic imaginable
i can watch
on every device i own and the best part
is that when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman my audience gets 25
off that makes it 15 for the entire year
that is not a lot of money for the
amount of enjoyment
that i know you will get from
curiositystream and the link
is right underneath this video